people ask me why do you risk death for  me  this is like welcome to New York  anything to declare I'm going to hang a  high wire between the two towers of the  world trade center and weapons huh girl  lark no matter where I was going or what  I was doing I was always searching  looking for the perfect place to hang my  wife whoa I need you to help me pull  this off I got just the guys now it  starts come on daddy i'm in a red zone  i'll figure out how to get the wire  across oh i think we should wait oh this  is extremely illegal not to mention  dangerous  my head is flipped out we were next time  to step on the wire I don't know if I'll  be able to take my first step your heart  will tell you what to do  man is obviously crazy we're just here  to watch him die  this isn't a game Philippe one mistake  out there but you're going to die  you